welcome to the lesson on brand strategy
in this lesson we will look at what the
brand strategy fundamentals are and what
distinguishes companies who will
approaches branding as an asset versus
those who consider branding as a product
since we're focused on digital we will
explore how it revolutionized some
aspects of branding and lastly we will
spend some time looking at building
brands for startups small businesses or
multi brand global organizations by the
end of this lesson you'll be able to
describe the role of the values vision
mission objectives and promises in
defining your brand explain how defining
your brand as an asset or as a product
will impact everything afterward discuss
how digital is impacting brands in the
role of the brand manager analyze how
brand marketing might differ from
various types of organization
brand values first let's domestic I what
a brand strategy is and isn't your brain
is not your product logo website or name
in fact your brain is much more than
that
it's more intangible it's the hard to
pin down feeling that separates
powerhouses and mediocre brands from
each other we can present the concept of
branding as a Yaqui first the values of
your organization are the ultimate
aspirational principles you stand for
from a brand marketing perspective it is
the starting point on which you perform
this work the fundamental motivation for
your decisions even if the world keeps
changing around you your brand core
values tend to remain very constant safe
god and the best-selling author wrote a
brand's value is merely the sum total of
how much extra people will pay or how
often they choose the expectations
memories stories and relationships of
one win over the alternatives the
opposite would be a commodity an item
with little or no perceived brand value
and you probably don't want that because
it would mean people are not seeking it
out if people relate to your brand
values they might be willing to pay a
premium
next comes the vision what do you aspire
to achieve where do you want to go it
represents the hopes and ambitions when
Microsoft revisited its global image in
1994 its tagline was where do you want
to go today
the branding campaign had Microsoft
spending a hundred million through July
1995 of which 25 million was spent
during the holiday shopping season
the values in division leads to your
mission at this point things becomes
achievable this is what you want to do
and who you want to do it with be it
employees or partners maybe now you have
a motivation and a purpose then it's
time to get strategic and define good
objectives that everyone can rally
around those objectives paves the way
for how you are going to make things
happen good objectives will help you
plan prioritize and most importantly
communicate what you want to do the last
and lowest level of the pyramid becomes
very specific and tangible it describes
specifically what you have to do and the
key performance indicators KPIs for
short will let you know how you are
progressing toward defined objectives
while the winning condition of the
previous point was communication this
one is all about typical project
management tasks actions who will own
them when they will be done what kind of
resources are required and what should
you expect once the tasks are and
actions are completed grand vision
behind every successful business is one
important ingredient an effective brand
and behind every brand is a story built
upon a strong vision to create a brand
you'll need two important elements a
brand mission and a brand vision while a
mission tells your investors team and
audience where your company is focusing
today a vision tells the most important
people around you where you're going
tomorrow it highlights where you hope to
find yourself in the future
mark Lipton the author of guiding growth
how vision keeps companies on course
doesn't believe in a vision statement he
argues that management inevitably gets
too dependent on a piece of paper on up
on conference room walls it is far more
important that all managers talk to
people about the vision in their own way
using their own language you don't want
to have it
statement that is too constrained it
should describe why the organization is
doing what it does it should be a
challenging and far-reaching purpose the
vision needs to address three
interdependent core topics a mission
statement presenting the organization's
purpose the reasons for being and a
claim to be able to solve something for
its customers a strategy explaining how
the mission will be achieved and values
the beliefs attitudes assumptions and
brazed
on a daily basis through all the
activities necessary to move the needle
through the strategy closer to the
mission and ultimately the vision
brand mission
a vision statement describes where the
company aspires to be a mission
statement is more tangible in a more
action-oriented version of the vision
statement it states clearly the purpose
the organization serves for its audience
a good mission statement is inspiring
transformational and often as a touch of
surprise of course you'll want your
mission statement to be closely aligned
with your corporate values and culture
and serves as an anchor to guide actions
now and into the future
Tesla is a good example we all associate
the name with fancy electric cars and
you might not even know where the name
originated from Nikola Tesla is the
engineer and scientists known for
designing the alternating current
electric system but Tesla's mission
isn't just about creating cool
self-driving cars the whole company is
about putting the environment first by
creating innovative solutions using
electricity so this includes cars of
course but also solar panels and clean
energy storage
grand objectives
the objectives describes a set of
decisions to reach short to mid-term
goals a strategy is going into practice
by splitting it up into specific actions
and tasks to be carried out and those
should be measurable through key
performance indicators the matrix which
can convey progress toward those goals
since there are as many visions and
missions as there are two strategies
conversely there are infinite
possibilities of brand objectives
nevertheless we can identify some common
objectives or brand marketers establish
an identity for the brand especially for
small businesses and startups measured
with surveys to understand if the bran
is viewed by your target audience
increase brand recognition of its unique
attributes such as visual symbols logo
packaging colors or even a unique audio
signature like the Terra of Dobie for
example again this can be measured
through brand recognition surveys we
often joke that a campaign without a
goal is merely an awareness campaign by
default but seriously speaking
increasing brand awareness is a
legitimate objective it represents the
percentage of customers who can recall
your brand and being top of mind being
the first brand that comes to mind for
your target audience as its value
engagement is also an important
objective and just like engagement in a
real relationship can mean very
different things what constitutes
engagement is your prerogative so don't
forget to clearly define it oftentimes
engagement on a website is defined in
terms of number of pageviews or time
spent on the website
while on social media engagement might
be the number of comments likes and
shares increasing the number of
customers who regularly purchase your
brand means increasing loyalty and when
you know that acquiring new customer is
a factor more expensive than keeping
existing ones discounts for a lot in
your profitability
in this age of social media and
influencers increasing advocacy can
ultimately lower your marketing costs
brand equity the value of your brand is
another way to measure how successful
your brand is your objective as a brand
marketer might be to increase brand
equity over time what's unique about
brand equity is the commercial value
that derives from consumer perception of
the brand rather than the revenue
derived from the product or service
itself that is the brand equity is from
the customer perspective
speaking of financial value we can avoid
market share the percentage of your
target market that our customers and
ultimately all of the ebola limb pack
your revenue margins
brand promise
your brand promise is a distilled
version of your company vision and
mission statement meant to inspire your
current and potential customers instead
of describing how you do what you do
your brand promise describes the
experience you deliver to your customers
it's what sets you apart and is a way
your customers can hold you accountable
for if your brand doesn't deliver what
you promised in time customers will all
do accountable and eventually they will
make you pay the price in today's social
media world vetting out broken brand
promises immediately impacts credibility
and your brand's perceived value and
this is true regardless of the type of
industry brand promises are constantly
being demonstrated through your actions
and tactics great brands also convey
great promises and expectations there
are a couple of key attributes of good
brand promises they are indicate
specific experience you can expect for
example Revlon says feel like a woman
make it obvious why you are different
M&Ms melt in your mouth not in your ends
is a great example make your brand
promise quantifiable the insurance
company Geico says 15 minutes or less
can save you 15% or more on car
insurance
use actionable language be more than
descriptive or aspirational what's the
endgame for example Disney says creating
happiness through magical experiences
keep it short and easy to understand
save money live better is Walmart be
bold be honest don't over promise
something you can't live for which
brings the next one speak to what
matters most to your core customers and
most loyal advocates the brand
experience needs to closely match the
brand promise you certainly don't have
to encompass every single element of
your brand experience in everything you
do but you want to be consistently
promoting what makes you stand out Nike
does an excellent job at conveying its
brand promise consistently be it a
full-page advertisement in a magazine or
a banner ad on a website with such a
strong brand they can simply use their
iconic black and white logo to state a
simple but powerful message Nikes brand
promise is so strong that people don't
wear shoes they wear Nike
brand as a product or an asset the
perception of a brand is defined by what
consumers see when they think about your
company and its products this perception
is influenced in two ways by what you
show people and by what the experience
if we contrast and compare products and
brands we can uncover some universal
truth companies make products consumers
build brands products can be copied and
replaced by competitors but brands are
unique and cannot be duplicated products
will eventually become obsolete but
brands can renew themselves innovate and
be timeless products are useful but
brands are significant how digital is
revolutionizing branding
consumer customers and employee behavior
continues to evolve along with
technology while marketing remains in
the crosshairs of disruption the
revolution started with the internet but
quickly accelerated due to social mobile
Internet of Things in the promise of
automation and artificial intelligence
take those three areas of transformation
as the Internet and the web evolved
organization migrated their service and
product online while updating their
technical infrastructure what we call
the mark tech stack those technologies
and services used by digital marketers
followed suit frictions were removed and
organizations had to stick their claim
on the web and social media marketers
were used to push their message on TV
radio newspapers and magazines but
consumers had a new voice and they share
their likes and dislike about brands
sometimes harshly
brands couldn't ignore the true voice of
their customers anymore
one of the most powerful shift in our
time is the mainstreaming of mobile
technologies and how it transformed our
behavior it's anytime anywhere
nature broke down the classic linear
sales funnel into a consumer journey
influenced by micro-moments
brand experiences
transformation imperatives consumers now
expect immediate response to customer
service requests on social media and
they would rather engage digitally or as
opposed to pick up the phone ups but the
popular inbound marketing and cell
service provider reveals that 80% of
customers expect companies to respond to
their social media post within 24 hours
even more 50% of customers claim they
would cease doing business with a
company that fails to respond to a
negative social media post those
negative comments are enough to
influence 62% of customers to cease
doing business with those brands another
study this time from Forbes reveals that
59% of customers said being treated as
an individual was more important than
how fast the issue was resolved that is
customer expect a personalized response
tailored to their needs and issues and
finally in another survey of 690 people
who attempted to contact a company
through social media for customer
support 57% of them expect the same
response time at night and on weekends
as during normal business hours
digital transformation roadmap
company puts it simply and elegantly no
rulebook will solve all of this a
transformation is not a science the only
way forward for companies to learn as it
goes and figure out how to apply their
sins as scale is built along the way
there will be important markers for
success the term digital transformation
puts the emphasis on technological
change but it becomes clear to anyone
who understands digital technology's
potential that what is afoot is less of
a digital transformation and more of a
fundamental rethink of the corporate
model for which digital technology is a
catalyst for some this transformation
will be rapid for others it will be much
more gradual and there will be numerous
roadblocks and challenges but in every
case it is inevitable it is a matter of
long-term survival and sustainability
contrary to other challenges the
organization have faced over the years
digital transformation is a never-ending
journey mirroring the fast-paced digital
landscape changes
how to build a brand from scratch
starting a brand from scratch or not
much isn't easy
this is commonly the case for start-up
small businesses or when creating a new
product what should it look like how
should it make people feel will it
resonate with my target audience those
questions
indium Li come up when you start
thinking about how to connect dots
between what you're selling and the
audience you're trying to reach when
faced with a writer's block follow these
seven steps we search your target
audience in your competitors identify
your core values choose you your
business name define your branding
attributes write a slogan and align with
your mission design your logo apply your
branding across your business and evolve
as you grow let's explore each of them
one by one
research your target audience first you
need to figure out your place in the
market and try to insert those three
questions find out who your lowest
hanging fruit customers are which
competitors names come to mind when
thinking about your product or service
category what your customers talk about
and especially how they talk about you
or your competitors what is the lingua
franca of your customers for example if
I'm going to launch a new brand of
luxury fashion apparel I might identify
Louie Vito as a competitor and using
social listening tool I can uncover what
comes up when people talk about the
brand
your core values next define your
brand's core values focus and
personality which words are associated
with your brand if your brain was a
person a car and animal which qualities
would describe him or her it sounds
funny but it works
is there a metaphor or a concept which
can describe your brand easily what's
your positioning statement
can you fill out the proposed statement
something like we offer water bottles
for hikers to stay hydrated while
reducing their carbon footprint unlike
utter water bottles brands we plant a
tree for every bottle you buy this is
pretty much what the Canadian company
10/3 dossier sells
choose your business name choosing a
business name is difficult and there are
many ways to do it you can make up a
completely new word like Kodak you can
reframe a totally unrelated word into
something else like Apple for computers
use a metaphor or a suggestive word in
line with your business like buffer you
can literally describe what you do like
the shoe company I thought it can be
easily imitated add or remove letters
like Tumblr or use Latin route to outer
world like Activia you could use an
abbreviation like HBO for own box office
combine two words Pinterest or Facebook
or turn several words into an acronym
like BMW
define your branding attributes once
you've got a name you'll need to think
about how you will visually represent
your brand its colors typography and
imagery color psychology isn't an exact
science but we know colors are more than
the simple look of your brand
they also convey the feeling you want to
communicate this infographic from the
logo company offer a nice overview of
the emotions and Association that
different colors generally evoked
right a slogan that aligns with your
mission a catchy slogan isn't necessary
but if you can think of something brief
and disruptive that you can put in your
Twitter bio website headlines business
cards and anywhere else where you've got
a few words to make a big impact it
definitely helps your branding efforts a
good slogan is short catchy and makes a
strong impression here are some ways to
approach writing a slogan of your own
you could state your claim a Deathwish
coffee use the world's strongest coffee
make a metaphor like Red Bull gives your
wing embrace your customers feeling low
hey al because you're worth it leverage
labels cards against humanity' a party
game for orrible people write a rhyme
fogers coffee the best part of waking up
is folders in your cup or describe it
literally I read yeah use woman's
fashion boutique
design your logo a logo is probably one
of the first thing that comes to mind
when people think about branding of
course it's the face of your company
after all and could potentially be
everywhere you want a logo that's unique
identifiable and that's scalable to work
on all sides and across all mediums
consider all the places where your brand
logo could be shown from your website to
your Facebook page profile picture -
even the little five icons you see in
your browser tab there are various ways
to think about a logo is it going to be
abstract at mascot or emblem maybe it
will simply use letters or words or a
combination of an icon and a few words
apply and evolve your branding your role
as a brand marketer will be to
consistently use it across every
possible scenario your role is to nudge
customers in the right direction make a
great first impression and manage your
reputation but remember you will never
have a hundred percent control over how
people perceive your brand initially you
should focus on three points build
customer trust and develop good
alliances rather than trying to beat
competitors at all costs welcome ideas
in foster a culture where changes are
welcome brands remain relevant when they
adapt to their changing environment the
classic build and they will come rarely
works watch listen and learn before you
move
Brenden kpi's once you have done all of
this there are three key performance
indicator that you want to track Brentt
awareness the percentage of customers
who can recall your brand loyalty or
retention rate the percentage of
customers the company has retained over
a given time period and its opposite
metric China rate or attrition advocacy
can be measured in different ways Net
Promoter Score is one method measuring
the frequency and quality of brand
mentions could be another
brands within a brand building and
nurturing brands within a multi brand
organization is somewhat similar to what
we've just seen for startups and small
businesses but it poses its own set of
challenges a multi brand strategy does
exactly what it says it approaches
multiple similar and competitive brands
of the same company under the disguise
of different brand names the idea behind
a multi brand strategy is often to
restrict and interfere with the
competition and in doing so capture a
larger share of the overall market
types of multi-brand strategies we can
distinguish three broad scenarios of
multi brand companies first case is when
the only thing that differentiates
products from competitors is the brand
image or identity for example FedEx has
various services like FedEx premium
FedEx cargo of FedEx slide FedEx office
etc here the differentiation is with
respect to the function of the brand
identity and the brand name is kept the
same if the main idea of the corporation
is shared among every product the
organization's offer then having multi
products under a single brand is a wise
approach in an efficient decision the
second scenario is when the distinction
is made through different brand names
but under a strong parent company name
products and services offered by
numerous Virgin Group Limited distinct
brands are always proud that they were
bred from a worldwide brand but this
strategy carries certain risk for
example if any of the underlying
products fail it might reflect on the
whole organization of course proper
management and supervision can
significantly minimize this risk in our
last example is where brand names are
kept distinct and the audience has no
clue as to which rent belongs to the
parent company larger corporations run
multi brand strategy has a way to
differentiate individual brands running
in the same market at the same time
sometimes there is even internal
competition amongst different products
sharing the same parent company or in
some cases the same product might be
branded differently in different
cultures and geographies for example so
car produced by March is a drug use
along with exercise diet and weight loss
to decrease elevated lipid levels the
exact same drug is known as lip X in
Australia New Zealand Croatia and a few
other countries
geographies you might have noticed some
products brands or stores I have
different names in different countries
there are several possibilities some
global companies come up with new brand
name in different countries because
theirs is already taken while expanding
in Australia
Burger King had to come up with another
name as Burger King was already
trademarked by a takeaway restaurant so
they called it on rejects in other cases
the brand needs to adapt to the local
language mr. Klain is known as Don
limpio in Spain master Lindo in Italy a
mr. proper in Germany pan proper in
pollen or mr. pop in Belgium and France
and yet they all share the same
bald-headed swung high who will help you
clean sometimes it's preferable to keep
a well-established local brand even
after an acquisition potato chips when
Lay's is called Smiths
in Australia and lastly companies have
to be careful about their brand names
because the meaning can be different in
front languages initially mercedes-benz
enter the Chinese market under the brand
name Ben Z which means rush to die or
this order time when Pepsi slogan Pepsi
brings you back to life the buted in
China as Pepsi brings you back from the
grave
okay we have covered a lot of ground in
thinking about your brand strategy
here's a summary of what you should take
away from this lesson thinking of your
brand values vision mission objectives
and action as a pyramid will help you go
from your aspirations to specific and
tangible outcomes over time the value of
a brand can surpass the value of the
individual products it represents a
brand is an important asset digital
already transformed a brand customer
relationship and it's not over so the
term transformation should become a way
of life for the organization we're
visiting your brand as if it were a
start-up can shed a new light and help
drive changes while other factors like
geographies and culture can
significantly alter its perception hi
there if you like this video subscribe
to the simple learn YouTube channel and
click here to watch similar videos to
nerd up and get certified click here